This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Step into the basement of Alex Hamilton's home in Frederick, Maryland, and you'll notice it has a distinct smell. It's wood dust and cigars. This is a nice cigar smoking area. The wood dust? That's from his carpentry projects. Alex's basement is his workshop. He's built things for every room in his house and outside too. Cote hooks.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。走进位于马里兰州弗雷德里克的亚历克斯·汉密尔顿家地下室，你会注意到那里有一种独特的气味。那是木屑和雪茄味。这是一个很好的雪茄吸烟区。木屑呢？那是他做木工活留下的。亚历克斯的地下室就是他的作坊。他为家里的每一个房间甚至室外都制作过东西。衣帽钩。
That's the table I made. A shed. This picture frame I made. A mailbox. Color coordinated with the house. Yeah, that makes stuff like that. Alex is showing my producer Rina Cohen around. Today he's building something for a beloved family member.
那是制作的桌子。一个棚子。这个相框是我做的。一个邮箱。与房子的颜色相协调。是的，他会制作诸如此类的东西。亚历克斯正带着我的制作人雷娜·科恩四处参观。今天他正在为一个深爱的家庭成员制作一件东西。
One of my dogs likes to go with me everywhere, so I'm making a bike seat just for her. Alex calls himself a retired perfectionist. Things don't have to be perfect for you to enjoy them. That's especially true for another of Alex's hobbies. He steps outside his house to show us a A sausage of a dog scampers up. Butter bean. That's my garden helper. Alex walks around his garden pointing out the fruits and vegetables he's planted. Those are blackberries, broccoli, brussels sprouts, tomatoes, sugar baby watermelon, artichokes, maybe not artichokes.
我的一只狗喜欢去哪儿都跟着我，所以我正在为她制作一个专属的自行车座椅。亚历克斯称自己是一个退休的完美主义者。事物不必完美，你也能享受它们。对于亚历克斯的另一个爱好来说，情况尤其如此。他走到屋外向我们展示 一只像香肠一样的狗小跑过来。黄豆。那是我的花园帮手。亚历克斯在花园里走来走去，指着他种的水果和蔬菜。那是黑莓、西兰花、抱子甘蓝、西红柿、糖宝西瓜、洋蓟，也许不是洋蓟。
Had one artichoke plant, I've never had an artichoke plant before. And there is a rabbit who kept eating it down to the ground. And a couple weeks later it would grow to be two or three inches tall. Then the rabbit would come back and eat it all the way down the ground. So good for him. I still haven't seen what an artichoke plant looks like. This pesky rabbit is one of the variables that distinguishes Alex's gardening from his carpentry. When he's in his workshop, there are things that he can control. The humidity, the shape, the size, the color, how smooth the finish is, or if you want to leave it rough or rustic. But as a gardener, he's found he has to let go.
有一个洋蓟植物，我以前从来没有种过洋蓟植物。有一只兔子一直把它啃到地表。几周后它会长到两三英寸高。然后兔子会回来把它一直啃到地表。真替它高兴。我至今还没见过洋蓟长什么样。这只讨厌的兔子是区别于亚历克斯园艺与木工活的变量之一。当他在作坊里时，有些事情是他可以控制的。湿度、形状、大小、颜色、饰面的光滑度，或者如果你想让它保持粗糙或复古。但作为一名园丁，他发现自己必须学会放手。
You can't control the weather, you can't control your rain, you can't control the humidity. So there are probably, I would say more than half of the variables for gardening, you have absolutely no control. Carpenters draft plans and stick to them. Gardeners, well, you have things that creep up on you all the time. Surprises are what make gardening so frustrating. Those weeds are really awful. I hate those things. But surprises are also what make gardening so rewarding. All these flowers here started from one flower, and they propagated. So at the end of the summer, we had this beautiful flower bed
你无法控制天气，你无法控制下雨，你无法控制湿度。所以园艺的变量中，我想说超过一半你是完全无法控制的。木匠会起草图纸并坚持执行。而园丁呢，总会有各种突如其来的事情发生。惊喜正是让园艺如此令人沮丧的原因。那些杂草真的很讨厌。我讨厌那些东西。但惊喜也是让园艺如此充满回报的原因。这里所有的花都是由一朵花开始的，它们繁殖了。所以在夏天结束时，我们拥有了这个美丽的花坛
and we didn't have to do anything. Alex Hamilton's hobbies are a metaphor for something very different. According to Psychology Professor Alison Gopnik, the different philosophies of the carpenter and the gardener play out every day in how parents interact with their children. I think it was kind of natural for people to think this is like going to school and working
而我们什么都不用做。亚历克斯·汉密尔顿的爱好是某种完全不同的事物的隐喻。根据心理学教授艾莉森·高普尼克（Alison Gopnik）的说法，木匠和园丁的不同哲学每天都在父母与孩子互动的方式中上演。我认为人们自然会认为这就像去学校上学和工作一样
and if I can just find the right manual or the right secret handbook I'm going to succeed at this task the right secret handbook, I'm going to succeed at this task the same way that I succeeded in my classes or I succeeded in my job. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring you our show from December 2017 on how to raise a human in our hyper competitive world. We'll study two different approaches to modern parenting and their consequences. Alison Gopnick is a professor of psychology and philosophy at the University of California Berkeley. She is the author of several books about children's development, her most recent book, The Gardener and The Carpenter,
如果我能找到正确的手册或秘密指南，我就能在这个任务中取得成功 正确的秘密指南，我就能在这个任务中取得成功，就像我在课堂上或工作中取得成功一样。本周的《隐藏大脑》，我们为您带来2017年12月关于如何在竞争激烈的世界中抚养人类的节目。我们将研究现代育儿的两种不同方法及其后果。艾莉森·高普尼克是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学和哲学教授。她著有多本关于儿童发展的书籍，她最近的一本书是《园丁与木匠》，
explores the different ways parents can raise kids and the consequences of those choices. Alison, welcome to Hidden Brain. Glad to be here. Your book is built around an analogy. Parents behaving like gardeners, parents behaving like carpenters. Unpack those analogies for me. Well, if you look at the prevailing culture of parents and caregiving in the United States,
探讨了父母抚养孩子的不同方式以及这些选择的后果。艾莉森，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。你的书是围绕一个类比构建的。父母表现得像园丁，父母表现得像木匠。请为我解读这些类比。好吧，如果你看看美国当前父母和照料文化的盛行，
even in Europe now. It's a picture that's a lot like the picture you might imagine if you thought about a carpenter. And the idea is that if you just do the right things, get the right skills, read the right books, you're going to be able to shape your child into a particular kind of adult. And that picture is very different
甚至现在的欧洲。这幅画非常像你想到木匠时脑海中的画面。其核心思想是，如果你做对了事情，掌握了正确的技能，阅读了正确书籍，你就能将你的孩子塑造成为某种特定成年人。而这幅画面非常不同
from the kind of picture that comes from the science. The picture that comes from the science is much more like being a gardener. Now one thing about being a gardener is you never know what's going to happen in the garden, the things that you plan, fail, but then wonderful things happen that you haven't actually planned. And there's actually a deeper reason for that. And the reason is that what being a gardener is all about is creating a rich, nurturing, but also variable, diverse, dynamic ecosystem in which many, many different things can happen, and a system that can respond
与科学所得出的画面大相径庭。科学得出的画面更类似于做一名园丁。关于做园丁有一点是，你永远不知道花园里会发生什么，你计划的事情会失败，但随后会发生你实际上并未计划的奇妙事情。其实这背后有一个更深层的原因。原因在于，做园丁的全部意义在于创造一个丰富、滋养但又多变、多样、动态的生态系统，在这个系统中可以发生许多许多不同的事情，并且是一个能够做出反应的系统
to the environment in unpredictable kind of ways. And I think the science suggests that being a caregiver for human beings is much more like being a gardener than being a carpenter. It's much more about providing a protected space in which unexpected things can happen than it is like shaping a child to come out to be a particular kind of desirable at all. I was surprised to read that the term parenting itself isn't very old. When did the term become popular and how did it come to be? Yeah it's interesting. The very word parenting which seems so ubiquitous and taken for granted now,
以不可预测的方式适应环境。我认为科学表明，作为人类的照顾者更像是园丁，而不是木匠。它更多的是提供一个受保护的空间，让意想不到的事情发生，而不是像把孩子塑造成某种特定理想类型那样。我很惊讶地看到“育儿”（parenting）这个词本身并不是很久远的词。这个词是什么时候流行起来的，它是如何形成的？是的，这很有趣。育儿这个词现在似乎无处不在且被视为理所当然，
is actually quite recent. So if you look in Google Engram, it's only around the 1970s in America that the word first begins to really take off, and then there's this kind of exponential increase from the 70s up to the present moment. This is Focus on the Family, hosted by psychologist Dr. James Dobson, the author of such best-selling books on the family as parenting isn't for cowards. Hey, parents, listen up to this. This could be revolutionary. You have to change the way you think about parenting because how many?
实际上相当晚近。如果你在谷歌图书词频检索（Google Ngram）中查找，大约在20世纪70年代的美国，这个词才真正开始流行起来，然后从70年代到目前呈现出这种指数级增长。这里是《聚焦家庭》（Focus on the Family），由心理学家詹姆斯·多布森（James Dobson）博士主持，他著有关于家庭的畅销书《育儿不是懦夫的专利》。嘿，父母们，听好了。这可能是革命性的。你必须改变对育儿的看法，因为有多少？
Amy Chou, I've knighted a firestorm by sharing the surprising details of her strict parenting methods in the book, Battle Him of the Tiger Mother. And if you think about it, parenting is a kind of strange word. After all, we don't whive our husbands or child our parents. What we say is that those are relationships. I am a child or I am a wife. It's not a kind of goal-directed activity that I'm doing that has a particular outcome that I'm trying to achieve.
艾米·周（Amy Chou）在书《虎妈战歌》中分享了她严格育儿方法的惊人细节，引发了一场风暴。如果你仔细想想，育儿是一个有点奇怪的词。毕竟，我们不会去“丈夫”我们的丈夫，或者“孩子”我们的父母。我们说的是那些是关系。我是孩子，或者我是妻子。这不是我正在进行的某种目标导向的活动，有一个我试图达到的特定结果。
And I think being a parent is a much better way of describing what that relationship is all about than parenting, then changing a child into something else. So it's interesting that that switch in some ways to a verb changes what we think about the activity. As you say, we don't start a friendship saying, in three years' time, I want my friend to become X, and I'm going to raise my friend to become that person that I want him or her to be.
我认为做父母是描述这种关系本质的更好方式，而不是“育儿”，也不是把孩子变成别的东西。因此有趣的是，在某些方面转向动词会改变我们对这项活动的看法。正如你所说，我们不会以这样的方式开始一段友谊：三年后，我希望我的朋友成为X，我要把我的朋友抚养成为我希望他或她成为的那个人。
Yeah, in fact, if you think about something like a friendship, of course, it's when friends are in bad shape, that the friendship counts the most. I think there was actually a historical reason why the word appeared in the late 20th century and the culture that goes along with it, which has become more and more intense, even in the 30 years since I had my own children. And I think that reason is that for the first time in human history, people were having children, especially middle class American people people who had not had much experience
是的，事实上，如果你想想友谊之类的东西，当然，正是当朋友处于糟糕状态时，友谊才最重要。我认为这个词在20世纪后期出现以及随之而来的文化其实是有历史原因的，这种文化变得越来越强烈，甚至在我有自己的孩子的这30年里也是如此。我认为原因在于，在人类历史上，人们第一次生孩子，尤其是中产阶级美国人，他们以前没有什么经验
of caring for children before. So one of the things, again, that comes out of the sciences for as long as we've been human, older brothers and sisters and cousins and aunts and grandmothers and the whole village has been involved in caring for children. And that meant that for most of human history, by the time you were ready to have children yourself, you'd had lots of practical experience in caring for children. And that meant that for most of human history, by the time you were ready to have children yourself, you'd had lots of practical experience in caring for
之前没有照顾孩子的经验。所以，科学得出的结论之一是，只要我们还是人类，哥哥姐姐、表亲、阿姨、祖母和整个村庄都参与照顾孩子。这意味着在人类历史的大多数时间里，当你准备好自己生孩子时，你已经有了丰富的照顾孩子的实际经验。这意味着在人类历史的大多数时间里，当你准备好自己生孩子时，你已经有了丰富的照顾孩子的实际经验。你还观察了许多不同的人，不仅是你自己的父母，还有许多其他人照顾孩子。20世纪发生的事情是，由于家庭规模变小，人们流动性更强，生孩子的时间也更晚。人们第一次生孩子时，缺乏照顾孩子的经验，但在上学和工作方面经验丰富。所以我认为人们很自然地会想，哦，好吧，我即将做的这件事，
children. You'd also watched lots of different people, not just your own parents, but many other people care for children. And what happened in the 20th century was because families got smaller and people got to be more mobile and people had children at a later age. For the first time, people were having children who hadn't had much experience of caring for children, but had had lots of experience of going to school and working. So I think it was kind of natural for people to think, oh, okay, this thing that I'm about to do,
这就像上学和工作。如果我能找到正确的手册或秘密指南，我就能在这项任务中取得成功，就像我在课堂或工作中取得成功一样。所以我认为这个历史事实是这种文化以及随之而来的焦虑感、担忧感以及这个价值数十亿美元的育儿产业在20世纪末开始兴起的主要原因。艾莉森指出，与其他灵长类动物相比，人类拥有一个特别漫长的童年。我们只是认为理所当然
this is like going to school and working. And if I can just find the right manual or the right secret handbook, I'm gonna succeed at this task, the same way that I succeeded in my classes or I succeeded in my job. So I think that historical fact is a lot of the reason why this culture and with it this kind of sense of anxiety and worry and also this billion dollar parenting industry all started emerging at the end of the 20th century. Allison points out that compared to other primates, humans have an especially long childhood. We just sort of take it for granted
孩子们需要很长时间的照顾，但这实际上在进化上是一个悖论。这里有一个有趣的问题，为什么会这样？至少有一个想法是，拥有漫长的童年期为你提供了一个受保护的时期，在此期间你可以弄清楚一个新的环境。你可以搬迁，比如从一个村庄搬到另一个村庄，或者从一个地方搬到另一个地方，童年给了你掌握这个新环境的机会。
that children need to be taken care of for a long time, but that's actually sort of evolutionarily paradoxical. And there's an interesting question about why it did that happen. And one idea, at least, is that having that long period of childhood gave you this protected period where you could figure out a new environment. You could move, say, from one village to another or from one place to another, and childhood gave you a chance to master that new environment.
我认为关于孩子们的许多看似奇怪的事情——他们既如此具有创造力、如此富有想象力、如此充满探索精神，却又如此不擅长照顾自己——在某种程度上都符合这幅图景。所以你会说，例如，人类经历的童年长度在某些方面甚至不仅适合园丁式父母的模型，而且实际上就是为园丁式父母的模型设计的，实际上就是为园丁式父母的模型设计的。完全正确。所以即使你能做木匠的事情，即使你能提前思考，这就是我希望我的孩子长成的方式，你知道我将参与这一套
And I think that a lot of the things that seem kind of strange about children, the fact that they're simultaneously so creative, so imaginative, so exploratory, and yet so bad at taking care of themselves, kind of fit that picture. So you would say, for example, that the length of childhood that humans experience in some ways perhaps not even lends itself to the model of the gardening parent, but actually is designed for the model of the gardening parent, but actually is designed for the model of the gardening parent. That's exactly right. So even if you could do the carpenting thing, even if you could think beforehand, here's how I want my child to come out and you know I'm going to engage in this set of
会使我的孩子以那种方式成长的程序，你这样做就已经破坏了童年的全部意义，因为从这个角度来看，童年的全部意义在于能够带来新的想法、在世界中生存的新方式、理解环境的新方式。你认为父母试图成为木匠会带来什么害害处？嗯，这是一个棘手的问题。我认为主要的害处是它使育儿的过程、生活变得焦虑、困难、紧张，并在各种不必要的方面感到痛苦。我认为这让父母感到如此，也让孩子们感到如此。
procedures that's going to make that my child come out that way, you would have defeated the whole point of childhood by doing that because the whole point of childhood on this view is to be able to bring new ideas, new ways of being in the world, new ways of understanding the environment to life. What do you think the harm is of parents trying to be carpenters? Well, I mean, it's a tricky question. I think the main harm is that it makes the process, the life of being a parent anxious and difficult and tense and unhappy in all sorts of ways that are unnecessary. And I think it makes it that way for parents and it makes it that way for children.
现在，关于父母的任何行为如何从长远影响孩子的问题非常非常复杂。所以，你知道，这个进化图景的另一个部分是每个单独的孩子都有他们自己的特征。每个父母也是如此。父母独特特征与孩子特征之间存在着复杂的互动，以至于实际上试图说，如果你这样做，那么从长远来看，你的孩子就会变成那样。
Now, the question about how any kind of behavior on the part of parents influences children in the long run is very, very complicated. So, you know, another piece of this evolutionary picture is that every individual child has their own characteristics. Every parent does. There's this complicated interaction between the parents' distinctive characteristics in the child's, so that actually trying to say, well, if you do this, then your child is going to come out like that in the long run.
这几乎是一场稳输的游戏，而且我认为我们没有太多证据证明这一点。所以我不想说，啊，好吧，如果你是一个木匠，那么你的孩子就会长大并拥有某种可怕的、疯狂的特征。孩子们以各种意想不到的方式成长。这才是重点。这不仅在于木匠模型让父母和孩子感到压力。阿迪森注意到了当今青少年的一些情况。你知道，在某些方面他们做得更好。
That's pretty much of a mugs game, and I don't think we have very much evidence for that. So I wouldn't want to say, ah, well, if you're a carpenter, then your children are going to come out and have some terrible, crazy feature. Children come out in all sorts of unexpected ways. That's the whole point. It's not just that the carpentry model is making parents and kids stressed. There's something Addison has noticed about today's adolescence. You know, in some ways they're doing much better.
他们取得了更多成就。他们不太可能冒险。他们怀孕或吸毒的可能性更小。但这伴随着一种焦虑，高度的焦虑，高度的恐惧。我认为这正是你从木匠的故事中所能预料到的。所以木匠的故事是这样的：你如此担心孩子能否成才，以至于你没有给孩子冒险、探索和自主的自由。如果不冒一些真正出错的风险，那就不能叫冒险。
They're achieving more. They're less likely to take risks. They are less likely to get pregnant or to use drugs. But that goes with a kind of anxiety, high levels of anxiety, high levels of fear. And I think that is kind of what you would predict from the Carpentry story. So the Carpentry story is one where you're so concerned that the child come out, that you're not giving the child the freedom to take risks and explore and be autonomous. And it's not risk-taking unless there's some chance that it could really go wrong.
我认为这是当前育儿文化的另一个问题。我们如此关心这些孩子将如何发展，以至于我们不愿意赋予他们进行冒险和外出探索世界所需要的自主权。所以我很好奇，这其中是否有些与你作为父母的目标有关。我认为你的观点是，通过创建一个孩子们可以学习和探索的环境，你培养出的孩子可能不那么焦虑，更能
And I think that's another aspect of the current parenting culture that's problematic. We're so concerned about how these children are going to turn out that we're unwilling to give them the autonomy that they need to be able to take risks and go out and explore the world. So I'm wondering if some of this has to do with what your goals are as a parent. The point that I think you're making is that by creating an environment where children can learn and explore, you build children who perhaps are going to be less anxious, more
适应力更强，更能应付摆在他们面前的生活变迁。我懂，这确实有道理。但也有这样一种情况，我认为我们的世界奖励那些能够做非常具体的事情并且做得非常好的人。因此，奥运会每四年举办一次。1998年日本长野冰上奥运会的冠军。现在17岁。当我看到人们在奥运会上赢得金牌时，他们通常是三岁就开始上滑冰课的孩子。或者，你看到有人加入了你所在城镇的管弦乐队，那个人四岁就开始上钢琴课。
resilient, more able to deal with the vagaries of life in front of them. And I get that, and that does make sense. But there's also the case that I think our world rewards people who can do very specific things and do them very well. So every four years the Olympics comes along. The winner of the Olympics in 1998 in Nagano, Japan, on the ice. Now 17 years of age. When I see people who are winning gold medals in the Olympics, those are usually kids who've started ice skating lessons when they were three. Or, you see someone who is joining the orchestra in your town and that someone who has started piano lessons when she was four.
有一些非常具体的技能，我认为这些技能很难学习，需要大量的时间、奉献精神和练习。如果你没有真正投入时间去早期做这件事，以后就很难掌握这些技能。尽管你可能会说，让孩子自己去弄清楚他或她可能想做什么，但如果一个孩子在14岁时发现她真的想成为一名滑冰运动员或芭蕾舞演员，在这个时候要真正擅长它可能已经太晚了。
And there are these very specific skills that I think are very hard to learn and take an enormous amount of time and dedication and practice. And if you don't actually invest the time to do that early, it becomes very hard to master those skills later on. And even though you might say, you know, let the child figure out what it is he or she might want to do, if a child discovers that she really wants to be an ice skater or a ballet dancer when she's 14, it's probably too late at that point to really be very good at it.
我想知道，这里的某些紧张关系是否来自于我们真正追求的目标。我们的目标是培养适应良好的孩子，还是培养成功的孩子？我希望这两者之间没有矛盾，但我有时觉得它们可能存在。好吧，这很有趣。
And I'm wondering if some of the tension here comes from what it is that we're actually aiming for. Are we aiming for children who are well adjusted versus aiming for children who are successful? And I wish there was an attention between those two things, but I sometimes think they might be. Well, it's interesting.
毫无疑问，育儿方法文化背景的一部分是父母在面对一个高度竞争的世界时产生的一种感觉，在这个世界中，他们的孩子在教育等方面的微小优势，对于确保孩子继续保持在中产阶级或上中产阶级地位至关重要。日益加剧的不平等以及这种不平等与诸如学业成绩等事物之间日益增强的联系，我认为给中产阶级父母施加了巨大的压力和恐惧，以确保他们的孩子踏上学业成功的轨道。当你审视这个国家的不平等现象时，我们看到富人格外能够以越来越有效的方式将他们的特权传给他们的孩子们。
There's no question that part of the kind of cultural background for the parenting approach. Is this sense that parents have of being in a very competitive universe where small advantages to their children in terms of their education, for example, are going to be absolutely crucial to make sure that the children continue to be in the middle class of the upper middle class. The combination of increasing inequality and increasing relationship between that inequality and things like academic achievement, I think puts a great deal of stress on and fear on middle class parents to make sure that their children get into that academic achievement truck. When you look at sort of the inequalities in the country, what we see is that the wealthy in particular are able to pass on their privileges to their children in increasingly effective ways.
如果你看看那些常春藤盟校里的孩子，你知道其中不成比例的很大一部分来自属于这个国家前5%或前1%的家庭。所以很明显，这些父母无论他们是园丁还是木匠，都在向他们的孩子传递某种东西，使他们的孩子能够继续前进，再次加入那5%或1%的行列。我认为在某些方面，我们向父母发出信号，做园丁是好的，但如果你表现得像个木匠，我们会以各种方式奖励你的孩子。
So if you look at the kids who are in the Ivy League colleges, you know a disproportionate number of them come from families who are in the top 5% or the top 1% of the country. And so it's clear that what these parents are doing, whether they're gardeners or carpenters, is passing on something to their kids that allows their kids then to go on and again, join that 5% or that 1%. And I think in some ways, I think we send signals to parents that it's good to be a gardener, but we will reward your children in all kinds of ways
在某些方面，我认为对于左右为难的父母来说，这里存在着一种紧张关系。我是希望我的孩子成长为适应良好、灵活且富有韧性的人（在这种情况下，园丁模型显然更好），还是希望我的孩子真正成为，正如我所说，成功的人？是的，我认为完全正确。而且我认为这两种信息都存在，我在四处宣讲这本书的过程中，我的经验是，直观上，父母
if you behave like a carpenter. And in some ways, I think there's a tension here for parents who are torn. Do I want my child to grow up to be well-adjusted and flexible and resilient, in which case the gardening model clearly seems to be better, or do I want my child to actually be, you know, as I said, successful? Yeah, I think that's exactly right. And I think both those messages are there, And my experience in going around and talking about this book is, I think intuitively, parents
觉得让家里的青少年熬夜到夜里两点学习SAT考试，试图获得能让他们进入某所大学而不是别人的微弱优势，这种做法有些疯狂。然而，一旦这种竞争故事在文化中开始，就很难抗拒，对吧？你很难让自己从中抽身。而且我是真心理解的。我的意思是，正如我在书中所说，我自己也感受过这种紧张。
feel that there's something that's crazy about having your teenagers staying up until two o'clock at night studying for their SATs and trying to get that little extra edge that's going to get them into the college as opposed to someone else. And yet, once that kind of competitive story starts in the culture, it's very hard to resist, right? It's very hard to pull yourself out of it. And I'm genuinely sympathetic. I mean, I've felt those tensions myself, as I say in the book.
我确实认为，就更大的文化而言，如果我们最终得到的是顶端的一小核心人群，他们和上一代人一模一样，那同样是令人不安的。人们改变的活力和灵活性、拥有不同的发展轨迹、走不同的道路，这些实际上才是一个大社会蓬勃发展的原因。我认为，在个人试图做到最好的内在动机（特别是在学术背景下，让孩子尽其所能做到最好）与整个社会所期望的灵活性之间，存在着一个非常有趣的张力。
I do think in terms of the larger culture, it's again, kind of disturbing if what we end up with is this kind of tiny core of people on the top who are all just like the people in the previous generation, dynamism and flexibility of people changing, having different developmental trajectories going in different paths, that's something that actually makes the society large flourish. And I think there's a really interesting tension between sort of the individual incentives to try to, especially in the academic context, to get children to do the best they possibly can, and what you'd want in society as a whole, that you'd want to have a sense of flexibility
和运动与活力。当然，这特别具有讽刺意味的是，学校实际上是为了训练人们适应工业世界而设计的。从某种意义上说，学校旨在制造机器人，因为它赋予人们现在机器人能够做到的技能。在后工业世界中，我们恰恰需要的技能——创新、创意、冒险——却正是这种非常狭隘的竞争性学术育儿文化所不鼓励的。稍后回来，我们将讨论儿童学习背后的科学，以及成年人在教导孩子时有时如何好心办坏事。请不要离开。
and movement and dynamism. And of course, it's particularly ironic because school was actually designed as part of trying to get people trained for an industrial world. In a sense school was designed to make robots in that it gave people skills that now robots are capable of doing. And in a post-industrial world, exactly the skills that we need, innovation, creativity, risk-taking are exactly the ones that we're not encouraging in this very kind of narrow competitive academic parenting culture. When we come back, we'll talk about the science behind how children learn and how adults can sometimes do more harm than good when it comes to teaching their kids. Stay with us.
研究人员曾经做过这样一个实验：一个成年人向孩子展示一个玩具，有时成年人会明确向孩子展示玩具是如何运作的，有时则不会。那是什么玩具？发生了什么？这是伊丽莎白·博诺维茨（Elizabeth Bonowitz）和劳拉·舒尔茨（Laura Schultz）所做的工作。他们做的是向孩子们展示这种复杂的、可以做很多不同事情的东西。它会发出吱吱声，有一个镜子，还有一个灯。问题是，孩子们会发现这个玩具的所有功能吗？
Researchers once ran an experiment where an adult presented a kid with a toy, and sometimes the adult explicitly showed the kid how the toy worked, and sometimes the adult did not. What was the toy and what happened? So this is work that was done by Elizabeth Bonowitz and Laura Schultz. And what they did was they showed the children this kind of complicated thing that could do lots of different things. It could squeak, had a mirror, it had a light. And the question was, would the children discover all the things that the toy could do?
他们发现的是，如果你把这样一个复杂的玩具给一个四岁的孩子，正如你所料，那个四岁的孩子会玩，并发现它能做所有的事情。但当实验者改变了他们说话的内容，在向孩子展示玩具时，实验者现在说：“这是我的玩具，我要向你展示它是如何工作的，”并做了一件诸如按响发声器之类的事情时。孩子们探索的可能性要小得多。他们所做的事情，某种程度上是理性的，就是按发声器，
And what they found was that if you give a complicated toy like that to a four-year-old, as you might expect, that four-year-old's play, and they find all the things that it could do. But when the experimenter just changed what they said, when they presented the child with a toy, where now the experimenter said, this is my toy, I'm going to show you how it works, and did one thing like squeak the squeaker. The children were much less likely to explore. What they did, sort of rationally, was squeak the squeaker,
做了成年人演示和建议他们做的事情。我们有许多类似的结果，孩子们对别人正在进行教学、别人正在扮演老师的极其微小的暗示非常敏感。这有一些优势，它缩小了他们将要考虑的选项数量。但就他们愿意考虑的探索范围而言，它也可能具有劣势。当然，游戏本身可以成为一种学习形式，思考游戏重要性的方法之一是思考人工智能以及游戏如何为我们训练机器人的方式提供信息。
did what the adult had demonstrated and suggested to explore. What they did, sort of rationally, was squeak the squeaker, did what the adult had demonstrated and suggested to them. And we have a number of different results that are like this, where children are very, very sensitive to quite subtle indicators that someone's being pedagogical, that someone's being a teacher. And that has some advantages, that narrows down the number of options they're going to consider. But it can also have disadvantages in terms of the range of expiration that they're willing to consider too. Now of course play itself can be a form of learning and one way to think about the importance of play is to think about artificial intelligence and how play informs the way we train robots.
你在书中谈到了这个想法，研究人员如何利用游戏来帮助机器人学习，这又告诉了我们关于抚养孩子的科学的什么信息？事实证明，让机器人生长的非常好的一种方法是给它一段早期的时间，让它只管玩耍，只管探索，只管尝试大量不同的选项，并获得大量关于系统如何运作的信息。例如，他们设计了一个机器人，它有一个早期的时期，可以只以这种奇怪有趣的方式四处跳舞，而实际上并没有试图做任何特别的事情。
You talk about this idea in the book, how are researchers using play to help robots learn and what does that tell us then about the science of raising kids? Well, it turns out that a very good way of getting a machine system to learn is to give it an early period where it can just play, it can just explore, it can just try out lots and lots of different options and get a lot of information about how the system works. So for example, they designed a robot that had a period early on where it could just kind of dance around in this kind of weird funny way without actually trying to do anything in particular.
事实证明，如果你给机器人一个四处跳舞的机会，弄清楚它的四肢能做什么，然后你给它一个具体的工作，比如，去把这块布捡起来。如果机器人有机会玩耍，它会更有韧性，这是游戏的有趣之处之一。我认为每个人都有这样一种直觉，即游戏是重要且有价值的。但当然，如果你真的想要一个特定的结果，比如测试中的特定分数，如果你不玩，如果你想要一个特定的结果，比如测试中的特定分数，
And it turns out that if you gave a robot a chance to just dance around, figure out what its limbs could do, and then you gave it a specific job, like, you know, go and pick up this piece of cloth. The robot was more resilient if it had a chance to play, and this is one of the interesting things about play. I think everyone has kind of the intuition that play is important and valuable. But of course, if you actually want to have a specific outcome, like a particular score on a test, you're always going to do better if you don't play, if you to have a specific outcome, like a particular score in a test,
如果你不玩，如果你只有非常具体的指导，你总是会做得更好。但如果你希望这种知识具有韧性，如果你希望某人能够灵活地说，好吧，我没有学会做这件特定的事情，但现在我可以把我所做的事情应用到别的事情上吗？那么游戏似乎确实扮演了深远的角色。例如，对于机器人来说，那些玩耍过的机器人，
you're always going to do better if you don't play, if you just have very specific instruction. But if you want that knowledge to be resilient, if you want someone to be able to be flexible to say, okay, I didn't learn how to do this particular thing, but now can I apply what I did to something else? Then play really seems to play a deep role. So for the robots, for example, the robots who would play,
你可以卸下它们的一条手臂，或者把它们推翻，它们仍然能够弄清楚如何去够那块布。对于那些只接受过该特定动作训练的机器人来说，情况并非如此。我认为这是游戏总体上能够做的事情的一个很好的模型。所以你曾经和你的孙子奥吉（Oggi）在厨房里，你在为煎饼打发蛋白，我明白你的孙子在模仿你，但并没有完全按照你的方式去做。告诉我发生了什么。
you could take off one of their arms or you could tip them over and they would still be able to figure out how to reach for the cloth. And that was not true for the robots who had just been trained on that particular action. And I think that's a good model for the things that play can do in general. So you were once in the kitchen with your grandson, Ogi, and you were whipping egg whites for pancakes, and I understand your grandson was imitating you, but not quite doing it the way you were doing it. Tell me what happened.
生活的巨大乐趣之一是和两三岁的孩子一起做饭，他们喜欢做饭，但与此同时他们效率极低。所以你知道什么，奥吉在打发蛋白，蛋白结果溅得到处都是蛋白壁画，他做这件事的方式远不如我自己做那样高效。但有趣的是，如果你跨文化观察，照顾者经常做的事情不是给孩子关于该做什么的指令，而是让他们参与进来。所以让他们承担一部分，比如打发鸡蛋。
Well, one of the great joys of life is cooking with two and three-year-olds, and they love to cook, but of course they're extremely inefficient at the same time. So you know what, Augie's whipping egg whites, the egg whites end up having egg white fresco all over the walls and he's doing it in a way that is not nearly as efficient as it would be for me to do it myself. But it's interesting that if you look across cultures, what caregivers often do is not give their child instructions on what to do, but let them participate. So let them take on a piece like whipping the eggs.
我和艾莉森主要关注的是幼儿是如何学习的，所以我请她谈谈大孩子。她说，虽然幼儿通过游戏和探索学得很好，但较大的孩子通过学徒制学得最好。他们模仿、练习、接受批评。但大多数学校的教学方式截然不同。艾莉森给我做了一个思想实验。所以想象一下，我们教棒球的方式就像我们目前教科学的方式一样。我们要做的就是让孩子们阅读关于棒球规则的书籍。当他们上高中时，我们会让他们模仿过去的著名棒球运动员。直到研究生院，他们才真正有机会玩这项运动。这差不多是
Allison and I had mostly focused on how young children learn, so I asked her to talk about older children. She said that whereas younger children learn well through play and exploration, older kids learn best through an apprenticeship. They imitate, they practice, they get critiques. But most schools teach in a very different way. Alison gave me a thought experiment. So imagine we taught baseball the same way that we teach science currently. What we would do is we would have children read books about baseball rules. When they got to high school, we would let them reproduce famous baseball players of the past. And it wouldn't be till graduate school that they would actually ever get to play the game. And that's pretty much the
我们教科学的方式。直到研究生院，你才有机会真正去做科学，而不是阅读科学或重构科学。特别是对于虚拟现实和计算机环境之类的东西，没有理由非得这样。孩子们实际上可以很早就进行探究、做实验和从事科学。我认为写作之类的东西也是如此。孩子们学习写作，但写作的方法是与一位优秀的编辑一起写作，看一个称职的人写作。
way that we teach science. It's not till graduate school that you actually ever get a chance to do science as opposed to reading about science or reconstructing science. And especially with things like virtual reality and computer environments, there's no reason for that to be true. Children could be actually doing inquiry and doing experiments and doing science early on. And I think the same thing's true for things like writing, for example. Children learn about writing, but the way to write is to write with a good editor to watch someone who's competent writing.
我认为我们的整个教育体系都可以更有效地朝着探索以及这种学徒制的方向发展。我想知道园丁模型和木匠模型之间的某些张力是否归结为社会要求年轻人做的不同事情。所以过去曾有一个时期，我们需要大量的人加入工业劳动力队伍，但越来越多的时候，我认为我们在寻找年轻人来做那种更高阶技能的事情。我想平均主义的未来学家会告诉你，在20或30年内，大学教育
I think our whole educational system could be oriented towards both exploration but also this kind of apprenticeship system much more effectively. I'm wondering if some of the tension between the Gardner and the Carpenter Model comes down to the different things that societies have called on young people to do. So there used to be a time when we needed large numbers of people to join the industrial workforce, but increasingly I think we are looking to young people to do the kinds of things that are much higher order skills. And I think the average futurist would tell you that in 20 or 30 years, college education
可能就行不通了，因为大学毕业的人能做的那类技能可能最终会被机器人取代。所以在那个时候，你真的需要具备更高更高技能水平的人。我想知道这是否部分是园丁模型和木匠模型之间的张力，因为如果你实际上需要的人不仅仅是简单地懂得如何在工厂里做一堆事情的人，而是懂得不仅仅是简单地懂得如何在工厂里做一堆事情的人，而是懂得更高阶事情的人，这需要一定水平的专业化和很长的培训时间，而这些是通过探索和游戏无法获得的。
probably isn't going to cut it because the kinds of skills that someone who's graduated from college can do will probably be done by robots. And so at that point, you really need people who have much, much higher levels of skill. And I'm wondering if this is partly the tension between the Gardner and the Carpenter model, because if you actually need people who don't just simply understand how to do a bunch of things in a factory, but who understand much just simply understand how to do a bunch of things in a factory, but who understand much higher order things that requires a level of specialization and a length of training that is not just going to be acquired through exploration and
它实际上必须通过非常长时期的系统和勤奋训练来获得。我们的社会正在发生的变化，是否是人们被木匠模型吸引的部分原因？嗯，这就是人们脑海中的画面。但同样，科学告诉我们的恰恰相反。所以，你知道，如果你比较一下，甚至从进化的角度来看，
play. It actually has to be acquired through systematic and diligent training over very, very long periods of time. And is it possible that the way our society is changing is part of the reason why people are drawn to the carpentry model? Well, I think that's the picture that people have. But again, what the science would tell us is just the opposite. So, you know, if you compare, even from an evolutionary perspective,
你知道，把我们和我们最近的灵长类亲戚相比，我们通常不像其他生物那样擅长执行专门的任务。我们非常擅长即兴发挥和寻找关于我们周围世界的新思考方式。这是一个新问题。我不知道该怎么处理它。我会怎么做？这确实是我们未来需要的技能。具有讽刺意味的是，这是一种你无法通过仅仅试图学习该特定技能来学习的技能。这似乎是一种源于自由和探索感的技能，即使在其他领域也是如此。所以我认为我们可能会被诱导去思考，
you know, compare us to our closest primate relatives, we're not actually as good at doing specialized tasks often as other creatures are. What we're very good at is improvising and finding new ways of thinking about the world around us. Here's a new problem. I don't know how to handle it. What would I do? That's really the skill that we're going to need in the future. And the irony is that that's a skill that you can't learn by just trying to learn that particular skill. That's a skill that seems to come from a sense of freedom and exploration even in other domains. So I think we may be kind of suckered into thinking,
如果我们希望儿童或成人在这个非常不可预测、多变的世界中取得成功，我们需要做的是赋予他们越来越高水平的非常具体的学术技能。我认为，即使你走到我所在的伯克利附近的硅谷，我认为他们也懂。所以，谷歌出名地给员工一天假去做他们想做的事，你知道，皮克斯（Pixar）把游戏屋作为其环境的一部分。所以我认为那种有趣探索的价值是科技界的人所理解的。但我确实认为这与这样一种感觉存在张力：这件事如此重要，必须加以塑造，而且你想要一个特定的结果。
well, if we want children or adults to succeed in this very unpredictable, variable world, what we need to do is give them higher and higher and higher levels of very specific academic skills. And I think, you know, even if you go down to Silicon Valley near where I am at Berkeley, I think they get it. So, you know, famously Google gives their employees a day off to do whatever they want, and, you know, Pixar has playhouses as part of their environment. So I think the value of that kind of playful exploration is something that people say in the tech world get. But I do think it's intention with the sense that this is so important, it has to be shaped and you want a particular outcome.
所以讽刺的是，为了获得好的结果，有时你不专门努力去获得这些结果，而是根本不担心结果，反而能做得更好。我认为这是我在书中讨论的科学的真正深层信息之一。艾莉森·高普尼克是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学和哲学教授。
So the irony is to get to good outcomes, sometimes you do better by not trying specifically to get to those outcomes and instead not worrying about outcomes at all. And I think that's one of the real deep messages of the science that I'm talking about in the book. Alison Gopnik is a professor of psychology and philosophy at the University of California Berkeley.
她著有多本关于儿童发展的书籍，她最新的一本是《园丁与木匠》。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你，尚卡尔。本期《隐藏的大脑》由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕尔特·沙阿（Parth Shah）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）。NPR节目副总裁是安娅·格伦曼（Anya Grunman）。我们今天的无名英雄是苏珊·斯坦伯格（Susan Stamberg）、琳达·韦特海默（Linda Wertheimer）、妮娜·托滕伯格（Nina Totenberg），
She's the author of several books about children's development, and her most recent one is The Gardener and The Carpenter. Alison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. This episode of Hidden Braille was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarelle. NPR's Vice President for Programming is Anya Grunman. Our unsung heroes today are Susan Stamberg, Linda Worthheimer, Nina Totenberg,
和科基·罗伯茨（Koki Roberts）。在一个关于育儿的节目中感谢他们是很合适的，因为在这些地方，这些女性被称为NPR的创始母亲。她们不仅帮助建立了一个伟大的机构，她们还字面意义上发明了我们今天所认为的公共广播。隐藏的大脑是她们遗产的一部分。今天的节目是NPR名为《如何抚养人类》的广泛项目的一部分。您可以在 npr.org/human 上找到该系列的更多故事。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果您还没有订阅播客，请花一秒钟时间订阅。你不会想错过任何一集的。
and Koki Roberts. It's fitting to thank them in an episode about parenting because around these parts, these women are known as NPR's Founding Mothers. They not only help build a great institution, they literally invented what we think of today as public radio. Hidden Brain is part of their legacy. Today's episode is part of an NPR-wide project called How to Raise a Human. You can find more stories from that series at npr.org slash human. For more hidden brain, please follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you haven't subscribed to the podcast, please take a second to do so. You don't want to miss a single episode.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm Sean Curvee-Dantham and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是肖恩·柯维-丹瑟姆，这里是美国国家公共电台。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。